each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
okay great thanks okay I recognize we're
running a bit late and I will make sure
I stay within 30 minutes this is work
that actually describes the kind of the
data management portion of the lead
project describes a little bit about the
Doppler source project which is a
complementary project I'll bet on a
smaller scale lead would not be possible
lead and Doppler source would not be
possible were it not for collaborators
primarily Dennis cannon who gave a talk
yesterday calvin drove amira
meteorologists said oklahoma dan reed at
University of North Carolina Chapel Hill
mohanram Murphy is the primary pyfrom
unidata which is a key part of this this
project Bob Williamson at NCSA sir
graves at Alabama rich Clark at
Millersville and others and my postdocs
and grad and undergraduate students
funding through National Science
Foundation and through Microsoft I want
to just describe some of the
functionality in the data subsystem I
primarily I'm kind of breaking this up
into into three pieces handling
community data this is something that
you know essentially we're kind of
making this distinction that will make
clear another pit in other pictures but
but we're handling but again we have to
we have to make this distinction so I'll
discuss the community data portion of
this and then also some higher level
data subsystem goals that we're trying
to achieve namely access and location
transparency how we're doing this and
then the personal data side of things
the individual workspace side of things
and then Doppler source typical analysis
that our users undertake and this is
this is very common I'm sure to
everybody in the room here is looking at
an observational looking at
observational data and comparing that to
model generated results so on the
left-hand side of your screen is is
hurricane katrina I believe this is
probably wind that's being visualized
here based on the coloring and this is a
go as satellite data on the right is I
DV I DD is a tool that out of unidata
three-dimensional visualization of
oh this is wind here also so by
comparing you can essentially view the
validity of your model or verify the
validity or model they I wanted to point
out is the kind of data you know they've
been a lot of discussions about about
image data and that's a piece of the
data that the meteorologist the meso
scale meteorologists are interested in
just a point back to dennis's talk
dennis was talking about you know meso
scale meteorology you know severe storms
hurricanes tornadoes that's the scale of
storm that that are our researchers are
are looking at I want to just point this
out to show that the range of data
products that that we're dealing with
the meet our data is surface data Iran
funds is upper air balloon data a cars
is aircraft NEXRAD level 2 and level 3
data is from the new Doppler radars go
estab is satellite data ETA data is
model generated data and caps is a new
small scale radar that University of
Massachusetts and Oklahoma are
developing to deploy on a regional scale
and it's essentially a sister project to
lead but if you look at what we've
plotted here we've just plotted
basically the the number of data sources
so these data sources are our relative
are accurate only in the context of the
fact that we're plotting these for an
area and 80 mile radius and in around
New Orleans this was actually done
before the flooding of our the flooding
of New Orleans we actually use the use
case based on a scientific American
article that apparently we were one of
the few that actually read and I see you
know predicted some of this but I just
want to point out the difference so you
know the ETA model data is probably the
largest data it's running at 41
megabytes per event I know people have
different terms of what events are if
this stuff is time is time stamped we're
dealing a lot with a lot of time stamped
chunks of data and it arrives at a very
slow rate we look at the cumulative rate
events per hour it arrives it
slow rate so it's coming once every four
hours what not as compared to say the
the caps data which is relatively small
it's 62 kilobytes but coming at a rate
of 600 events per hour and this is again
just for the ten sensors on next rad you
were just comparing me the next red
level to data coming from the
large-scale Doppler radars comes in at
one thirty five to seven minutes whereas
the caps dad is coming in at a much
higher rate is coming in at once every
30 seconds and if you look at the
distribution so there's distribution of
products those imagery data there's
there's pure numerical data and if you
look at that file distribution obviously
we're skewed based on the caps data but
you know the larger scale doubt is is a
is a small portion of the the 41
megawatts is a small portion of the
total distribution so these are the what
leaders days they needed the seven
canonical to dust the canonical seven
data sets that we're trying to make work
and then we'll expand into other data
sources just just to kind of pull out
the research challenges that that may
get lost in the in the in a set of
slides is here we're doing architecture
work building tools to acquire use and
store the data the representation of the
temporal procedural relationships in
that provenance automated metadata
generation is a big one for us and you
know the whole notion of the temporal
data and how to tag that and identify it
I like this slide this is something that
actually started with our program
manager at National Science Foundation
Steve Meacham and then I worked it to
kind of give it a a slant that I thought
was a little more descriptive 4 lead and
then he kind of passed back and forth
and then he then use that version it
kind of gone through a couple different
iterations but so but I think it
captures very well I think what leads
goals are in exposed as some of the data
management issue you know oops we're
portal base so we've got a user sitting
at a portal you can look at the top
third of the slide as being the the
users the client-side services that that
the user needs in order to
interact with with with the system you
can look at the bottom third as being
essentially the the computational
infrastructure that's actually running
the forecast models and in some of the
dynamic capability and in the middle are
the resources that enable all of this
we've introduced a notion of a of a
workspace and this is unlike the the
notebook you know the notebook that's
come up in a number of other talks the
notebook the user records done what
they're observing about an experiment
the works based on the other hand is
actually capturing the experiment itself
so it's a slightly different notion and
i would i would consider the two one is
more you know petted pedo pedo scale
based you know and back in the
infrastructure and the other is more
sitting on users a user's laptop there's
tools that that support the user a
geospatial GIS GUI query service you'll
see these in other diagrams the
experiment builder experiment GUI this
is Dennis's work you know the whole
experiment space constructing these
essentially workflow experiments which
are based around before casting and
executing those and then the catalogs
and the ontology in the back end that
support that with a break between with a
split between in here you see the
community catalog versus the personal
catalog and that's kind of flowing
through that notion that I thought I
started out by describing down on the
bottom we've got information coming in
from from sources we've got the benefit
of working with you need data and
someone else I think tomislav mentioned
that you know he's working with I'm
expecting the data products to be coming
in via idd unidades idd which is an
internet data distribution system we're
assuming that also so you know we're not
actually going to the these saw sensors
themselves but we're relying on the fact
that there is a dissemination system
that's bringing them to a client and we
can install that client on the certain
sites in our test that but what we are
doing in and this is where we're lead is
taking its your three challenge is
making more direct connections and this
would be in the case of the Casa radars
where the user can you've got a sensor
actuator relationship going on where the
user can actually while specific users
anyway can actually you know use that in
from using information coming from these
these small-scale radars to steer the
radar antennas mentioned this in his
talk so what you're seeing in this
diagram is actually that that
relationship going on where these the
instruments themselves feed into a data
mining which data mining in this case is
essentially a meso scale detection
algorithm which is it's looking for
tornado signatures so you've got this
running and in when something definitive
enough is detected then kicking off in
notifying workflow which kicks off a
workflow engine which kicks off a
workflow and this simple workflow is and
we've got three data products that feed
into some quality some QA our model
execute a certain analysis that's being
done so that's what's being depicted
here and that's actually the legend
describes that but you've got that
dynamic feature and again this is
something you know we've got after year
two of the project we've got the
infrastructure in place and our now
working on this this dynamic capability
those results are what's being published
in the catalog on behalf of the user in
their personal catalog the resources
we're dealing with our tools you know
Alabama you be not just forecasting
stuff simulation is all forecasting
stuff some of the data repositories and
whatnot so the tools that enable this
pulling it back to a data product focus
you know we've broken down I'm sure
anybody who's gone through this effort
will will appreciate the the time
involved in getting this work getting
this worked out in a collaborative
project but basically just identifying
what the resources are you know we've
got we've got meteorologists in on the
project and we've got you know
educational people but then we've also
got two variants of computer scientists
I mean those that that are essentially
doing research and understand the
service or in an architecture and those
that are essentially doing code
development and don't necessarily
understand or don't necessarily buy into
or whatever the service-oriented
architecture I mean so there's tensions
there also so you know just identifying
what our resources and distinguish
the geodata products from other
resources and viewing those all as one
thing that has to be managed and
managing those in a coherent fashion as
it has been an evolutionary process and
has taken time within our geo data
products you know we look at
observational data model generated data
and we've got collections we've got to
deal with so there's that that here are
key above that and that's actually very
non-trivial for those of you are dealt
with it you know data analysis results
so it's not all you know model results
it's not all observational data workflow
scripts are another form you know and in
the model input parameters you know one
of the key things we want to do is tie
those input parameters to the output
results through a system of provenance
to better explain the data products so
tracking all this in this context and
this is key and I've mentioned this
couple times already but we're making
the distinction between these community
data products which are those canonical
seven data products I just listed from
the personal data products which are
derived out of product scripts input
configuration parameters and stuff that
that essentially though the by-products
of an experiment and then also external
data products and this is where Doppler
source comes in because it's something
quite novel here so in order to
accommodate me owner of the kind of
grapple with with you know how do we
deal with these these community products
and what now we're kind of we're saying
this is a this is common amongst you
know this this group but we're saying
okay we've got a sandbox the services
that are in the sandbox we'll talk this
lead metadata schema which it took us
nine months to pull together those that
sit outside those those data catalogs or
data sources that sit outside the the
lead sandbox will communicate to
services in the lead sandbox by doing a
crosswalk a meta data crosswalk from
whatever there's famous to the lead
metadata schema common stuff but it
still had to be it still had to be
worked out and agreed upon I'm not this
is this is just to show evidence of
something that's something that really
does this is not just me waving my hands
the leading so we came up with this lead
minute dad
a schema and we're using it you know not
so much necessarily in the you know and
the data sources themselves but but to
represent to describe data products
between services that are communicating
I took us nine months to reach agreement
on this this was this was relatively
painful I'll show you the next slide
we're leveraging fgdc in order to do
this and now we've got an adoption by
the Casa project our sister project
which is nice we'll get some some cross
fertilization because of that because
that's a fairly interesting dinosaurs
we're leveraging fgdc for this who we've
extended it you know what we're
supporting the mandatory parts of that
and we're essentially you know we see
our are some of the the metadata
attributes that we need to describe some
of the rich meta data attributes we need
to describe things like precipitation
you know humidity and some of the stuff
that the user wants to be able to query
on would it was essentially fall into
this entity and attribute piece going
back to the community catalogs or the
community data sets again we're working
with unit data unit data has something
called their threads catalog it's
basically an xml web certain web
sexually essentially it's a piece of XML
sitting in a web server that has URLs a
list of URLs to data products that are
sitting on an opened app server in order
to bring these into a service-oriented
architecture we've I think I think
compromised here it would compromise the
model the service or an architecture
model to do this but we yanks okay we've
essentially we essentially import them
we've got three threads catalogs here a
B and C through a threads plugin so
we've actually built something into the
lead resource catalog and the resource
catalog which is you know inches built
as a service the web service crawls the
threads catalogs periodically I think
it's doing it nightly and it indexes the
data products using leucine and accepts
queries as
name-value pairs it's it's working for
us now however we are we're supporting
more than we're using a controlled
vocabulary and an ontology and concepts
so the queries can actually be issued
spatially and temporally and over these
other conceptual terms but yes we are
right now supporting files but open tab
allows the sub setting and aggregation
of products so we'd like to support you
are back in storage you know we r comma
dating the support of those as well and
and how that ocean flows into the front
end we're not clear yet we're still
working on that
all day
as of right now that's what we're doing
yeah and yeah and and we recognize
things like this would be desirable but
not right now haha I'm proud of this
okay all right but obviously this is
fine as long as you know everything's a
threads catalogue which is it isn't
going to be the case so you know new
data catalog comes along we're not going
to write a plug-in for every data
catalog that we get so the new model
that works is actually a model where
essentially you've got a newly-minted
catalog x the catalog registers itself
as a service provides a crosswalk from
its schema to the lead metadata schema
someone can ask or who serves
precipitation data the service registry
can say well X does and the query can be
issued master model that we're moving
toward this is our you know get it up
and get it going model and because the
threads catalogs are such an important
part of what we're doing that model will
stay there that threads plugin will stay
there the you know one of the goals is
access and location transparency and
that's basically just described in the
diagram right here you know I've
mentioned the the lead metadata schema
we've got a a single query interface
over which the user can issue high-level
queries we're restricting to a common
vocabulary the CF standard vocabulary
coming out of uni data also those you
essentially issue a query specifying
concepts like precipitation is a concept
for us that the query service asks the
newest ontology this is anh thanh
ontology that's being developed at
Alabama to break the stone into terms
that the different catalogs can
understand in our community catalog and
our personal catalog the query gets
issued over those different backends and
then the results come back and the data
is often in binary and as as I just
alluded to it it's often file-based and
we're using a system of global ideas to
uniquely identify everything which is
actually quite interesting when we get
into supporting
the temporal streams that were that
we're working in in Doppler source is is
naming these things as one of our
challenges the geospatial GUI and I will
hustle along here I'm a little bit
slower here than I want it to be
geospatial GUI we're using the Minnesota
map server user can specify you just see
very quickly here that the user can
specify a bounding box that queries for
data products the data products come
back it's got a temporal specification
in geospatial specification along with
some of these data categories this is
still evolving the personal data catalog
is kind of evolving out of the notion
that that you know your local file
system is not adequate I think this is
an argument that doesn't need to be made
in this this group so there are there's
going to need going to be need for data
storage in the in the in the grid you
know in the Terra great in whatever and
this is addressing those needs so as I
mentioned you you know we're not
essentially recording what users have
done though users the user annotations
can be part of this but we're primarily
focusing on derived in temporarily
changing data products the user access
is through their personal space Dennis
showed another version kind of browser
version this would be the lead in page
to that I'll skip that the gigs we view
a typical work from typical workflow is
a gather the data products run the
forecast analyze the results we can
gather more data products based on the
analysis of the results running a
shorter smaller forecast analyze the
results going over a period of 12 hours
the workflow is executing the whole time
there's a notification service thats
collecting status messages and down on
the back end is the mind is the personal
catalog that's interacting while the
experiment is executing I will skip this
slide basically it's showing one of the
things we're trying to do is is
organized give the user here are cool
organization of their files that doesn't
necessarily model what's actually being
stored in the metadata catalog but it
just gives them a look and feel that
that they're comfortable with but I did
want to point out the difference between
the metadata catalog and the files
themselves or may
that separation this is something that
other people are doing as well it's a
common I me an emerging way of
organizing data or essentially you put
you put your catalog in a database you
can get the rich query access over it in
the actual file access is somewhere else
it's kind of like SRB and mcat does
something similar archiving the derived
data products i showed you the the
workflow in the previous slide down in
the orange this is that same workflow
abstracted a bit or identifying number
of reads and writes for trying to get
estimate of what these work what the
provisioning for the personal catalog
would be i won't go into that just
essence of time but we've got a number
of nodes those nodes are writing their
their intermediate products into the
personal workspace the workspace
supports multiple users simultaneously
the workflow itself will be running on
Terra grid machines the service itself
would be running also you know in
proximity to a chair grade machine if
not on a tear good machine the personal
workspace is oxidized uses oxidized
version 6.0 which is built on Globus gt3
and the database for that right now is
my sequel and I was just talking with
memo who said that is my sequel that is
dropping indexes so this is new this is
this is good to know we don't want that
we're already worried about performance
it is okay okay oh so that was the drive
data plug so if you take this whole
drive data product coming out of the
previous slide and you look at that
through time you know this this
particular instance we're recording this
everything with it that's an instance
through through time so user user be
would have four active experiments and
you're capturing again you're capturing
at the evolution of an experiment
through time and the challenge here is
determining the number of versions
necessary to preserve a meaningful sense
of an object's evolution over time so
this is capturing the temporally
changing aspect of this Providence I I
threw this in here mainly based on the
discussion that that I've been having
with with another person in the audience
but I will just send her this
I didn't go on with this but Providence
is a is a spect of this so where does
this work with Doppler source let me
take just a couple slides to explain
what we're trying to do without their
source basically Doppler source came as
it was funded partially we got an
equipment grant through Microsoft to
fund a sequel server windows box running
sequel server with two terabytes of disk
storage we are we've got an arrangement
with Oklahoma University through the the
I rads project to get level two next red
level two data come in directly on
Abilene from Oklahoma we are processing
that essentially it's coming in as raw
data we're converting it to netcdf we're
tagging it with metadata and you know we
want to be able to provide computation
you know user invoke computation think
the open invoking data mining routines
whatnot that we host on a web server
farm and to essentially augment the the
resources that we can provide for the
user the raw data the converted data
plus the the derived data products the
challenges we're taking on right now
yeah we've got the stream coming in you
know we know what its needs are and sure
let me go to another slide we've got you
know there's things we want to do level
3 data tomislav talked about a different
like stage 3 data which is slightly
different level 3 data is is essentially
level 2 data that's been put through the
WDS s on whether decision support system
and certain feature based on tags are
recorded such as the presence of meso
scale phenomenon and what we're trying
to do is tag those two together and use
this feature base to organize the
temporal streams you know people are
going to request streams of data we
organize them as based on features and
then we store and retrieve them based on
features and you know how do we do the
global ID assignment of this you know
how do we you know is mentioned
one mentioned yesterday is you know you
don't want to return just a raft of
low-level events you want to have some
meaning at the collection level how do
we have all these collection always keep
those as additional resources and
whatnot ow again the stuff we're doing
right now is very low level you know
where our web server farm is Linux so
we're doing the line x 2 to the dotnet
interface to make sure we can get our
jobs started off there so it's kind of
back and kind of stuff we're doing right
now and we're also working on expanding
this to include the cost of data because
the radar data you know the radars are
not a meteorologist but they're somewhat
uninteresting and that all of the
descriptions the meta descriptions are
identical where the cost of radars are
different because they actually scan a
smaller region and they can spawn scan
so basically the metadata for describing
them is quite a bit richer so it's more
interesting from our perspective we've
got the GIS we've augmented this with
the positions of the of the radars in
and around the Louisiana area I'm sorry
Louisiana Indian area anyways we were
just trying to understand the data
products and this is just showing a
correlation between the arrival this is
a rival for it darn it this is the
arrival for the single radar and showing
that the correlation to whether you know
in terms of this is the the product at
every three hours we sense it every
three hours and see how much dad has
arrived so every three hours you get an
unalloyed somewhere between 80 megabytes
down to 10 megabytes up to a lot 100
megabytes so we're looking at trying to
look at we're basically trying to gauge
how much we can store you know how much
capacity we need what not and where this
fits in you know a couple different
things this is again this this is in my
mind you know this is the external data
source that's going to test the
generality of the architecture that
leads put in place for supporting data
and and so it's it's a it's and I think
it's a nice it's kind of pushing the
edge for leading and I like that i think
i think lead the lead community the data
group needs that testing it also allows
us to play with things like the virtual
global ID and you know in essentially
applying the metadata schema to novel
these now derived products using
computer science based at
mining algorithm so it's it's a nice
platform a nice kind of playground for
us to kind of push the edge beyond what
the lead project is funding other
questions I know everybody wants to get
out I don't blame you I'm antsy I'm
probably an teased of everybody well I
think yeah we looked at SRB basically
you know I made the distinction between
the personal catalog and the community
products we needed a a back-end storage
that was not opened app that could store
both SRB i think is viable we know we
looked we could make we could get the
the meta data catalog to work with mcat
we could use mcat to store some of the
lowest level stuff however I think
political pressures kind of stepped in
the way and I think also unit data would
like to see a solution that is more
consistent with their community which is
not a bad idea because you know they're
very involvement is a big strength than
they've got a huge community so we ended
up going with a a solution that you know
data is is coming up with that uses
pieces of RLS for its naming primarily
naming and indexing of replicas but it's
it's also going to be unique to unit
data in that it will probably have an
open DAP kind of interface which which
will benefit us